blast how
you know when it came to approaching six
two
or six take two um what was like your
approach from like
you know you just put out an insane ep
insane bonus edition you're on a lot of
hooks you got the mozzie record going
crazy
the jason cash record is crazy i'm sure
that there's so much stuff that we
haven't heard that's
going to be on some big projects as well
but like what what's like your approach
when it comes to approaching a
collaborative effort as opposed to like
kind of what you've been doing the last
year and some change i mean for the main
thing for me was
really just sticking to the script and
what i mean by that is just like
knowing what got me here and um i feel
like what the people really wanted was a
6k part 2 because that really impacted
the city
you know beno gave gave me the olyu for
people to even know who i was like i'm
gonna always give him as much credit as
i can because
who knows you know but um i feel like my
my main motive was just making the
impact over
anything just being as far as a solo
artist i'd rather
make an impact in the city